خلافات في تقريبا بين
فريقين ه هل نحن امام مرحله تحول في هذه
الخلافات ام انها ما زالت تحت
[موسيقى]
السيطره زين العابدين هي ربما اكثر من
خلافات بين فريقين بل ان ربما كل قضيه
تتعلق بسير المعارك في غزه باتت محطه خلاف
بين مجموعات مختلفه اي ان الموضوع هو
القضيه بالاساس اذ ترى في بعض الاحيان ان
هناك اتفاق على سبيل المثال بين وزير
الدفاع يوف جلنت وبين رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو على واحده من القضايا في
هذه الحرب المتعلقه بسير هذه الحرب لكنهما
يختلفان في مواضيع اخرى وهذا نراه يتكرر
في عدد من الملفات والقضايا المتعلقه بسير
المعارك في غزه في المرحله التاليه او
اليوم التالي ما بعد الحرب على غزه ورؤيه
كل جانب لهذه المرحله في القياده السياسيه
والعسكريه نهيك ايضا عن ملف الاسرء
المحتجزين في قطاع غزه وهذا ايضا مثار
لاختلافات كثيره ايضا تظهر بين الجانب
السياسي والجانب العسكري والامني في
اسرائيل لو اردنا الحديث اولا عن قضيه ما
يبحث هذه الليله على الاقل في المجلس
الوزاري الامني المصغر وفي مجلس الحرب
هناك قضيه تحويل الاموال للسلطه
الفلسطينيه هي اموال مستحقه من عائدات
الضرائب وفقا لاتفاقيات اقتصاديه سابقه ما
بين السلطه الفلسطينيه و بين الجانب
الاسرائيلي اسرائيل تجبي هذه الضرائب
وتقوم بتحويلها للسلطه الفلسطينيه منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب بدا الجانب الاسرائيلي
باحتجاز هذه الاموال ونتحدث عن اموال
طائله زين العب دين وتؤثر كثيرا على
الاقتصاد في السلطه الفلسطينيه وفي الضفه
الغربيه تحديدا جزء من هذه الاموال ايضا
يحول الى غزه وهذه الليله هناك بحث وفقا
لمطلب امريكي بالعوده واعاده هذه
المستحقات الماليه للسلطه الفلسطينيه الا
ان هناك تعند تحديدا من قبل وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي بتلس موتتش الذي اعلن حتى
اللحظه الاخيره ما قبل انع قاد هذا
الاجتماع بانه لن يتراجع عن قراره ولن
يقوم بتحويل هذه الاموال للسلطه
الفلسطينيه المقترح الذي سيبحث هذه الليله
تم بحسب وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه اقتراحه من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه وهو تحويل الجزء المتعلق بغزه
من هذه الاموال بعهده الى عهده دوله ثالثه
الى حين انتهاء الحرب لكن من غير الواضح
بعد ان كان المجلس الوزاري المصغر سيصادق
على مثل هذه هذا المقترح وسط هذا التعنت
من قبل بيتل ايس موتش واخرون ايضا في
المجلس الوزاري المصغر لا سما وان كل قرار
حاليا يتخذ على مستوى مجلس الحرب بقياده
نتنياهو وبيني جانس وا وزير الدفاع يتم
تحويله ايضا لهذا المجلس الذي يشارك فيه
بين كفير و سموتريش وبالعاده يقومون بعرق
مثل اتخاذ هذه القرارات وهذا يساق ايضا او
يندرج على قرارات اخرى مهمه من بينها قضيه
الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه بينما تدفع
المؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه الى التوجه الى
صفقه تبادل يصر نتنياهو وجانت وايضا
الوزراء من اقصى اليمين المتطرف الى
مواصله هذه الحرب ومزيد من الضغط العسكري
على امل ان يحققوا شيئا في هذا المضمار